Các bạn có xin đồ tại trưng đông tiếp tục các động đến tìm trường năng lượng thần cầu,
các cua ra trua đang hình trường trường khai tất cả xảy pháp bảo đảm ảnh năng lượng.
Cái thay lan, chính phổ giới sự trủ trí của thủ thường án ujin trong viên Rau Kun đã tăng trữ lượng dầu đều.
Lý mức đã ứng khoảng chiếm làm ngày, đồng thời nâng mức sự trữ vất bộ của sân nghiệp kinh sân sầu,
từ một phân trăm lên bà phân trăm và tạm dân sức khẩu như liệu tinh trế hoại trường là vào nghiêm này.
Thái lan cũng lên cái hoại tăng tì lệ phà trụ như lựa xin học trong viên dân,
nếu giá giấu thư giới tăng mạnh và tên những nhập khẩu trực tiếp sân dầu đi dân thành phẩm,
nếu phó với khủ hoàn, con tại hành Quốc, tổng thống liên trên miân chỉ trích việc tăng giá sân bất thường
và trước sân có giấu hiệu lợi dục tình hình. Chỉ vụ nữa này đừng xem xép áp chần giá sân,
khi quà thể thống cảnh báo ninh tạnh quan, cho bị giúp khẩu dựu giấu trí lợp và tăng cử giá sân xác phân của như liệu.
Các động tháng này và nãy nấu lực của các nước trói nhà bởi đảm ồn cút nâng lộn đình,
cho những bến động địa chính trị và sát dầu tòn cầu.